Mmmmm...bacon! Few of us can resist its temptation.
I mean, did you know that 43% of Canadians
would choose bacon over sex? At least that’s
what a 2010 survey found. Or did you know
that is was included in the first meal ever
consumed on the moon by Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin?
This single strip of bacon alone is 43 calories.
In perspective, here is the same amount of
calories in apples and broccoli. It’s easy
to see which might fill you up more easily...but
then again, who just eats one piece of bacon?
Looking at this another way, 100 grams of
apple is around 50 calories, while 100 grams
of bacon is around...550 calories. 68% of
these calories come from fat, with almost
half being saturated.
So it may...or maybe not surprise you that
the average American consumes nearly 18lbs
or 8 kg every year! That’s 44,000 calories
every year, making sliced bacon a 4 billion
dollar industry in the US alone.
Even 65% of Americans said they would support
bacon as their national food.
But different countries around the world actually
use different cuts of a pig for bacon. For
example, Canadian Bacon is from the loin,
the British use shoulder and ham bacon, and
Americans make belly bacon. Overall, around
11% of a pigs standard weight can be used
for bacon.
So why are we so obsessed? Well when bacon
is heated, the fats melt and the sugars and
amino acids have a very unique chemical reaction.
This specific reaction releases a medley of
around 150 volatile organic compounds from
the bacon which float through the air and
create the amazing smell, ultimately stimulating
your mouth-watering response. So it’s not
just the snack you desire, but the smell itself
is a perfect example of chemistry at work,
stimulating your brain and body.
Our modern culture loves bacon so much that
‘bacon mania’ is a classified movement!
From bacon toothpaste, to bacon air fresheners,
and even...bacon condoms, some people can’t
get enough of it!
But bacon isn’t all good. Not only are 4
strips of cooked bacon worth nearly half your
recommended daily intake for salt, but most
bacon - and other things like lunch meats
- are treating with a chemical called sodium
nitrite. This keeps the meat looking red and
fresh, instead of turning its natural grey,
but has also been implicated in a lot of health
concerns. These nitrites react with amino
acids during cooking, forming nitrosamines,
which are known carcinogens, increasing your
risk of developing cancer. A diet high in
sodium nitrites may also lead to a decrease
in your body’s ability to transport oxygen
properly in your red blood cells. On the other
hand, nitrites help to prevent bacterial growth
that can cause botulism.
Bottom line is, when you do pig out, keep
it in moderation - and a few antioxidant rich
fruits and vegetables to go along with it
won’t hurt either!
Hungry from looking at all this bacon? Find
out why FOOD PORN or photos of amazing food
is so stimulating in our newest AsapTHOUGHT.
There’s some yummy science behind it, so
click the screen for that.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode and giving you a free audiobook at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book ‘The Dorito Effect’ by Mark Schatzker,
because we’ll take any chance we can get
to read about science and chips at the same
time. But seriously, it’s an interesting
look at the link between nutrition and flavour
and how we’ve modified foods through the
years. You can get a free copy at audible.com/asap
or any others of your choice from a massive
selection!
Don’t forget to ask your burning questions,
and subscribe for more weekly science videos!